the graph below shows the depreciation
of a motorcycle's value over time and
they show us the graph and they say
during which two-year span does the most
rapid let me underline that the most
rapid depreciation occurs so
depreciation just means loss and value
and this is this shows the motorcycle's
value and you can just eyeball this here
let's just let's just look at this chart
saying this is saying right when the
motorcycle is brand new when it's zero
days old or zero years old i should say
it is worth ten thousand dollars and
then when it's one year old it looks
like it's about a little over six
thousand dollars and when it's two years
old it looks like it's about i don't
know
five thousand then at three years it's
about four thousand and so on and so
forth so this curve shows how it
depreciates how it loses its value and
they're saying when is the most rapid
depreciation occurring and they don't
want to notice know what year they want
a two-year span
when we have the most rapid depreciation
now one thing you can look here you can
just kind of eyeball and you can say
look the beginning of this curve is the
steepest part it's steepest over these
two years and over any other two-year
period out here it's a kind of a very
shallow it's almost flat in terms of
how quickly it's losing value so it's
not losing value too quickly so if you
just eyeballed it you would just say
well it's the it's the most rapid
depreciation is occurring over the first
two years from zero to two years up to
this point because you can see the curve
is getting less and less steep the
entire time but it's most steep over
those first two years now if you didn't
want to just eyeball it and really
verify that it loses the most value over
the first two years in any other two
year period let's look at the let's
actually calculate it
so after the after from zero
so let me write two year
period
and like let's write lost value
or we could call it depreciation
either way so from zero to two years we
went from ten thousand dollars to what
looks like about five thousand dollars
right that looks right about five
thousand
so we lost five thousand dollars of lost
value then if we go from one to three
years what happened one to three years
that's the other two year period you go
from one to three years
we started it looks like about 6100
maybe 6200 or so and we went to 4 000.
so we lost about i don't know 2200
dollars we lost about 2200 so definitely
less than what we lost in the first two
years
then if we look at
the two the second through the fourth
year we went from about five thousand to
about four thousand so we lost about
looks like about one thousand
looks like about one thousand dollars in
value maybe a little less well yeah
that's about what we went from years two
to four
two or about five thousand or maybe a
little under maybe a little under four
thousand so i'll give it a little bit
more value so maybe it's like 3 800
right there so maybe on the order of
and then if you go from year 3
to year 5
year 3
to year five we're going from about
four thousand dollars to looks like
about thirty six hundred if i had to
eyeball it so it looks like we lost
about four hundred dollars so anything
as we go further and further in time
each two year period we're losing less
value so then finally if we go from four
to six years looks like we're at about
i don't know 3 800 and we end up at
about i don't know i don't know what
this this value looks like it's about
30 now i would say it's maybe 3 500 or
maybe we're going from 37 i don't know
it's about we're losing about 300 it's
steep it's shallower than it was before
so the most rapid depreciation occurs in
the first two years and you didn't have
to go through this exercise you could
have just looked at the chart you say
hey look how steep it is this first two
years compared to all of the years after
that